should be alright
there it goes oh it's quite spectacular
with Ian and my second you actually
think I'm I live for and far too much I
thinks I talk about it too much and I
saw Ron I live for him now I used to do
lots of chemistry boron I kind of moved
away a little bit from boron now but I
really like it
boron is an interesting element it's one
of the few that I've actually made
myself while I was at school or on six
the top of group 13 Tomic number is five
so it's a metalloid so elemental boron
is a metalloid which basically means it
has some of the properties of a nonmetal
and some of the properties in a metal I
next an or oxide of boron with magnesium
heated it up and then it's a really
dramatic reaction when you add water at
the end to try and destroy the magnesium
boride that's formed because you get
puffs of gas coming off which burst into
flames rather like little anti-aircraft
guns but boron itself was rather
disappointing it sort of brown powder I
mean there's more of a powdery Brown
boron
there are several crystalline sort of
types of allotropes of boron and there's
one actually is really really hard so
the black crystalline boron is actually
very very hard
it's just just below diamonds on Mohs
scale of hardness so I believe and
actually in America there's a town
called boron it's in California it's got
a population of about 2,000 which
actually was set up around the world's
biggest borax mine which is in
California weight used to be transported
on trains of mules and the company that
produced it used to have as their
trademark a train of 20 mules sort of
going along a great interest as chemists
recently well over the last of 50 maybe
sort of 60 70 years and have been the
boron hydride or borings Sabourin
hydrides are basically clusters of
Boron's with-with-with clusters with
hydrogens around them and one of
particular use and interest in the 50s
was one called Penta boring spacey Penta
fives got five pawns in it
and Penta borane was investigated so
during the Cold War or the early part of
the Cold War as being a rocket fuel
it actually burns with a green flame
they actually calls it the green dragon
because it burns the very very hot green
flame and also because it's pretty toxic
which I can actually show you if I
so I can ish it's pretty not going to be
spectacular and boron complexes or borax
compounds are used in variety of things
it's not a very expensive materials used
in washing powder particularly per
borate which when you heat adapt turns
into in the washing machine when the
water gets to sixty degrees centigrade
it turns into hydrogen peroxide which
can then bleach the clothes and this is
why the famous washing powder is called
Percel because the PIRs stands for per
borate and the s silk stands for
silicate so it's really a mixture purple
rate and silicate okay so this isn't
Penta boring because Penta boring
spontaneously combust in the air this is
just a benzene veronik acid it's an
organic compound with some born in it so
hopefully we can see we should be able
to see if I can get some on the end of
my spatula that should be able to burn
with some sort of green flame
hey there it is you can also see a bit
yellow which is the organic bit going as
well should be alright
there it goes oh that's quite
spectacular with Ian
okay